in today's video we are covering our
first Saint worshipped by both the
Catholic and Eastern Orthodox churches
revered for having first introduced
Christianity among the ruse these were a
pagan people of Nordic descent who ruled
over a vast land in the early Middle
Ages from the Baltic to the Black Sea
but her holy title should not fool you
as she did not dedicate her life solely
to prayer and converting the heathen the
Saint was a ruler the regions of the
Principality of Kiev and one of the most
powerful women of the early Middle Ages
most of her life is lost to the shadows
of history while the rest has emerged
from the mists of legend in today's by
graphics we're gonna learn how this
widow of a prince with an infant son
defended her throne against insidious
suitors hostile tribes and invading
nomadic Raiders most of all we're gonna
hear the incredible story of how she
avenged her husband with acts of
escalating ruthless cunning please
welcome today's protagonist princess
olga of kiev
[Music]
before I begin the story of how princess
Olga defended her family and her lands
allow me to give you some context who
were the roost people and what lands did
they rule over the roost sometimes
called Varangians were people of
Scandinavian ethnicity who had founded
the ki Evan Roose political Federation
that lasted from 862 to 1240 to this
state was located in modern-day Belarus
Ukraine and Western Russia the capital
of this Federation was Kiev in
modern-day Ukraine kevin ruse can simply
be translated as the bands of the ruse
of Kiev the Scandinavian origin was
first mentioned by a Byzantine diplomats
and eventual saint named Burton who
first recorded their presence in his
annals of 839 but most of the stories
about the origin of the ruse comes from
the primary chronicle known also as the
tale of bygone years an early Russian
text from the 12th century according to
the Chronicle the original dwellers of
the area in the midnight century had
invited the ruse described also as
Vikings to rule and maintain order in
their country one of these Vikings was
called aurora and he founded his own
dynasty which ruled over the area for
more than seven centuries the first Tsar
of Russia ivan the fourth also known as
Ivan the Terrible was a direct
descendant of Rick's the key Evan Roose
however had ceased to exist as a
political entity long before Ivan
between 1237 and 1242 the federation was
overrun by the unimpeded advance of the
Mongol hordes the federation was divided
into smaller disjointed countries which
eventually evolved into Ukraine Belarus
and Russia but now let's go back to rear
it because his bloodline is directly
involved in our main story today at an
unspecified time in the second half of
the 9th century
rurikid established his capital in
novgorod and his men had begun raiding
the surrounding area in true viking
style even going so far as attacking
Constantinople when ruat died of natural
causes his firstborn son Igor was too
young to rule
was put under the care of Oleg of
Novgorod after more campaigns to conquer
and consolidate territories around
Novgorod Oleg moved the capital to Kiev
to seize the enormous wealth amassed by
two former allies of Rorick in 912 Oleg
died and in a very interesting wait
zu a prophecy had foretold that his
favorite horse would be the cause of his
death
Oleg a superstitious man had made sure
the horse was cared for as far away as
possible from him when he heard that the
horse had died Oleg considered himself
free of the curse and mockingly kicked
at the poor animals skull he chose
poorly though a snake beneath the
carcass was startled bit Oleg on the
first and killed him in the meantime
Igor had come of age and so he ascended
to the throne formally becoming Prince
Igor of Kiev by this time he had already
married a rang young lady named Olga
following in the footsteps of his father
and his guardian Igor continued engaging
in successful conquests raiding the
neighboring territories and exacting
heavy tributes to fill his coffers but
he Gore was greedy
and he wanted more in 945 he considered
paying a visit to the lands of the DREV
Williams local tribe which had been on a
lighter Uruk joining his Raiders in
attacks against the Byzantine Empire
later the Dravidians have paid tribute
to Oleg but had stops when he kicked the
horse's head since then the trevelyan's
that paid what was effectively
protection money to a rival landlord
igor saw this as a perfect occasion to
collect some late payments and set off
on his mission according to the primary
chronicle he raided the land of de
Reaver and collected his tribute by
violence but on his way back to Kiev he
still felt a thirst for more gold and
riches he ordered his men to return home
except for a few followers with them in
tow he rode back to the trevelyan's
desirous of still greater booty like
Oleg he had tried his luck one too many
times his returning party was spotted by
DREV lian's who reported back to their
leader Prince Moll the Prince had had
enough proclaiming if a wolf come among
the sheep he will take away the whole
flock one by one unless he be killed if
we do not thus kill him now he will
destroy us all the travelling warriors
then rode forth from their city of
coricidin massacred eager soldiers and
reserved him for a gruesome execution I
will leave the description to Byzantine
chronicler Leo the Deacon they had bent
down to birch trees to the princes feet
and tied them to his legs they let the
trees straighten again thus tearing the
princes body apart with this threat to
pose the dread Liam's plans their
counter-attack they would take over Kiev
itself not by conquest but by marriage
prince muhyul ordered for some
emissaries to visit the now widowed olga
to ask for a hand in marriage it is not
clear if this was a common habit at the
time or if mal was simply very arrogant
back in her capital olga awaited for
eagles return in vain by aside she had
her boy son Seattle sloth who was too
young to fight let alone rule Mars idea
was that
becoming his stepfather he could
influence that or Prince into doing his
own bidding so the delegation of DREV
Lian's sailed a boat along the river
denis pro mall had sent 20 of his best
advisers to put forward his proposal
clearly believing they would be welcomed
with open arms this is when the primary
chronicle and our own story centers on
Olga the princess sent her own
emissaries to ask for the reason of the
trevelyan's visit they announced that
they had slain her husband because he
was like a wolf crafty and ravening they
also said the prince ma was a good
leader RINs that Olga should come to the
land of deriva and marry him
Olga's reply was what the delegation
expected in fact she said that their
proposal was pleasing to areas but asked
for the delegates to wait on their bows
and that they would be picked up the
following morning as the 20 trevelyan's
wait is Olga at the halt of her castle
prepared to give them their deserved
welcome the morning after when the roost
came to collect the travelens the latter
demanded to be carried into the castle
in their own boat Theru complied as this
was the same order they had received
from Olga when they arrived at the
castle
they found the surprise that lay waiting
for them during the night the princess
had commanded for a large deep ditch to
be dug within the castle walls
the trevelyan's did not have time to
react as the ruse held them botan all
inside the trench the delegates
protested to no avail as Olga ordered
they'd be burned alive with her simple
trap the princess had wiped out a large
part of the enemy leadership this though
was only the beginning of her revenge
prince Maul was unaware of what happens
in Kiev so he was not suspicious of the
message he received from Olga she
insisted that she was eager to meet that
she would only do so if mal sent more of
his own distinguished men to pick her up
the prince who it is safe to say was
quite a gullible man agreed to it and
gathered more of his chieftains warriors
and advisers to pay homage to the ruse
princess when this second delegation
arrived in Kiev Olga demands it that
they bathe before she would give them
audience the travelens surely tired
sweaty and covered in dirt from the
journey eagerly complied and entered the
bathhouse that had been readied as they
relaxed inside the sauna they were
startled by a sharp noise somebody was
locking the doors from outside their
attempts to force their way out were
futile in horror they heard Olga's Stern
voice through the wooden doors she had
just given orders to set the house on
fire first by earth then by fire the
princess regions had sealed her first
two murderous campaigns against the
enemy tribe with their leadership almost
entirely decapitated but she wasn't done
yet
before mal could become suspicious of
the long absence of his men she sent
another message I'm now coming to you so
prepare great quantities of mead in the
city where you killed my husband that I
may weep over his grave and hold a
funeral feast for him Mead was a popular
alcoholic beverage in medieval times
made with fermented honey and water when
they received the message the travelens
sent to work repairing gallons of meat
and a lavish feast Oh arrived shortly
thereafter with a small escort in tow
she arrived at Igor's tomb and asked her
men to build a funeral mounds around
which the trevelyan's gathered for the
funeral feast some Dravidian who was
smarter than the others asked what had
become of the two delegations they had
already sent to which the sly ogre
replied that they were on their way
escorted by her late husband's guard of
honor was the trevally and judgment
clouded by the rivers of freely flowing
needs they swallowed the lie very easily
Olga passed her mentor wait upon the
trevelyan's insuring their cups whenever
empty she waited patiently until they
were all drunk and at her signal the
massacre started taken by surprise her
enemies fell one by one under the blades
of the Roose according to the Chronicle
five thousand
revans were cut down at the red funeral
a 5,000 man massacre still was not quite
enough Olga was bent on complete and
total reprisal again moving swiftly the
princess returned to Kiev and gathered
her army the boy Prince Seattle Slav
joined his mother and together they
marched back to the land of driver he
was just a child's but when his troops
made contact with the enemy
see artist Slav was the first to cast a
spear from atop his horse his arms were
obviously too weak and the spear barely
cleared the horses ears regardless
Olga's generals Vienna Lodz and asmin
proudly announced that the prince had
already begun battle and pressed the
vassals to follow his example there is
charged forward and completely routed
rebellions the surviving men women and
children of the unfortunate tribe sought
refuge within the walls of their main
city escora stone auger and air troops
besieged the city but the travelens
valiantly repelled their attacks they
knew that this was a fight for their own
existence and would resist to the bitter
end
in the meantime other towns and cities
of their lands had capitulated since
we're now living in relative peace with
the ruse they were of course paying
their tribute after one year is Carsten
still stood firm and Olga had to think
of another plan to resolve the stalemate
one day the besieged citizens received a
message from the princess why do you
persist in holding out all your cities
have surrendered to me and submitted
tribute so that the inhabitants now
cultivate their fields and lands in
peace but you had rather die of hunger
without submitting to tribute the Durov
lien started to buckle and said that
they would be glad to pay tributes but
they could not trust her as she was
still determined to avenge eagle Olga
was apparently relieved to start
negotiations with the defenders and let
them know that she had considered her
slain husband to have been already
avenged not once not twice but thrice
after all she had already massacred two
delegations plus those who had attended
the funeral feast in order to seal the
peace she demanded one last small
tribute from the DREV lions after which
she would return home Olga's request was
surprisingly modest as she realized that
the city had been impoverished by the
siege she only wanted three sparrows and
three
from each house the trevelyan's were
elated they collected the small flocks
of six birds from every household and
send them to olga who promised to lift
the siege the following morning this was
the last act of Olga's plan of total
revenge and annihilation if one year a
frontal assaults and siege engines could
not achieve victory the intellect of a
princess definitely could and she would
do so by turning innocent harmless pet
birds into a weapon of mass destruction
she ordered her soldiers to take one
bird each and to attach to their talons
a piece of sulfur bouncing cloth when
night fell the soldiers released the
sparrows and the pigeons their silent
wings carried them back to their nests
under the eaves of the homes one by one
the houses of his-- carsten were lit by
fires soon the whole city was burning
its inhabitants either killed in their
sleep or running in terror unable to
extinguish the flames some of them fled
outside the city walls but they were
quickly seized by Olga's soldiers she
kept the eldest captive and some of the
others sold as slaves and many more were
killed on the spot this was the final
and total triumph of princess olga of
kiev Viktor of escora stand scourge of
the trevelyan's mother of sparrows
[Music]
in the following years until 948 Algar
continued to act as regent for her boy
Prince Vieira Slav the trevelyan's had
been completely subdued and paid regular
tribute to the ruse the Principality was
a peace and grew prosperous finally the
princess set on a journey to
Constantinople or as the risk called it
Tasha grabs the city of Caesars The
Chronicle does not offer a reason for
this visit but we can assume it was of a
diplomatic nature therus in the
Byzantine Empire had a love-hate
relationship characterized by raids and
attacks by both sides but also by trade
and occasional cooperation it was during
this period that Byzantine emperors
actually started to recruit ruse
warriors to their elite Varangian guard
in 948 the emperor was Constantine the
seventh thing upon meeting Olga
immediately took a liking to her
impressed by her beauty and intellect
constantine remarked that she was worthy
to reign with him we have learned by now
that Olga did not take well to suitors
but in this case reaction was well less
violent at least the princess did not
outright reject the proposal but simply
stated that being a pagan she could not
marry a Christian monarch but if he
really insisted he could baptize her the
Emperor agreed and with the assistance
of the patriarch of Constantinople had
her converted into the Christian
Orthodox faith The Chronicle reports
that Olga accepted very eagerly the
teachings of the church like a sponge
absorbing water at a baptism she was
christened Helen Aaron's the Emperor
acted as a godfather at her own
insistence after receiving the
sacraments Al Jarreau Helena was
summoned by Constantine who renewed his
proposal there was no obstacle now she
should become his wife but she replied
that this was not possible he was her
Godfather after all which made her his
daughter in the eyes of the church and
of course it was unlawful for a man to
marry his own daughter the emperor
considered her reply then simply said
Olga you have outwitted me he then
covered her in gifts gold silver and
silks and he bade her farewell algorithm
to Kiev when she received a message from
the Emperor apparently those gifts were
not entirely for free and
he expected slaves wax furs and
mercenaries in return
Olga was unfazed and she simply replied
to the Byzantine and voy that she would
pay back her due only if the Caesar was
willing to spend as much time in Kiev as
she had spent in Constantinople
it is not recorded whether the Emperor
paid her a visit so we will assume that
he didn't and she had outwitted him yet
again now as they recently converted
Christian Olga tried to spread her
newfound religion among her people
starting with her own son but Prince the
outer Slav was not convinced fearing he
would be mocked by his subjects if he
did so augur accepted this refuse all
this only defeats so far but according
to The Chronicle she prayed day and
night for God to forgive the heathen
souls of see outer Slav and the ruse by
956 Prince the outer Slav had come of
age and hungry for conquest he built a
valiant army and set off on several
lengthy campaigns away from Kiev when he
was away the land of the Reese was
invaded by the pecheneg zat nomadic
tribe they swept through the country and
eventually attacked Kiev
Olga shut herself up in the city with
her grandsons vara pulk Oleg and
Vladimir now it was her turn to be under
siege
the only chance of survival for the ki
Evans was to send a message to a relief
force on the other side of the river to
Negro a clever boy whose name was never
recorded volunteered for the sortie he
could speak the language of the passion
eggs and so he simply walked out of the
city with a bridle in his hand asking
the nomadic riders if anybody had seen
his horse the ruse worked and he was
able to jump into the river and swim
over to the other Shore their relief
army soon arrived and their general
called pratik convinced the leader of
the passion eggs that his was just the
vanguard of a massive army led by Vieira
Slav these roots were incredibly crafty
and apparently all of their foes were a
bunch of yokels the veteran eggs they
bought the lie and agreed to a truce in
the meantime Olga had sent a messenger
to recall the prince who returns in time
to decisively drive the passion eggs
back into the steps for many years viata
Slav remained in Kiev
finally fulfilling his duties of ruler
in addition to his early honors as a
conqueror but in 969 he announced to his
mother and his advisors the boyars that
he had no intention to remain in Kiev
anymore during his earlier campaigns he
had established his base and this is
of period-- slaw that's where bullies
riches were concentrated he said gold
silks wine and various fruits from
Greece silver and horses from Hungary
and Bohemia and from wrists furs wax
honey and slaves if that was the truth
yet a point but all go it was sad to see
him depart once again now aged 70 the
princess was in poor health and begged
him first to await her death and then go
wherever he would like the Prince yield
heads but he did not have to wait long
three days after algorithm-- a de plea
she died her son her grandsons and all
of her people wept for her in mourning
Algar given commands not to hold a
funeral feast for her as was part of
pagan tradition instead she had called
for a Christian priest performed the
last rites in a subdued ceremony it was
her grandson Vladimir the great who
eventually converted all of the Kiev and
roost to the Orthodox faith but Olga was
hailed by later generations as equal
among the Apostles for role as a
precursor to the widespread introduction
of Christianity in the primary chronicle
it is written that she was as the dawn
precedes the day she shone like the moon
by night and she was radiant among the
infidels like a pearl in the mob she was
the first from the roost to enter the
kingdom of God and the sons of Roose
thus praised her as their leader for
since her death she has interceded with
God in their behalf princess olga of
kiev was canonized in 1547 officially
becoming Saint Olga she is probably the
only mass murdering saint in history but
I might be wrong on that one other
monarchs and popes have been canonized
over the centuries and these rulers can
rarely have a career without getting
their hands at least a little bit bloody
so I really hope you enjoyed today's
video as I mentioned at the start it's
difficult to discern which part of
Olga's life belong to the realm of
history and which belong to the realm of
myth I mean what parts do you think were
true and what do you believe was just
medieval propaganda leave a comment
below also please do share and subscribe
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]